est ce que le baby boom du confinement
va nous achever après locaux vides
ça c'est la grosse question alors est-ce
que le baby boom du confinement va nous
achever après le qu'ovide c'est quand
même une question extrêmement complexe
parce que chaque terme de la question
peut être remis en cause d'abord y
aura-t-il un baby boom du confinement
c'est pas sûr du tout parce que quand on
voit le nez de l'autre au milieu de son
visage toute la journée dans la même
pièce surtout quand on est confiné dans
un studio
on n'a pas forcément toujours envie de
faire un bébé avec lui ou elle
et puis en plus il faut jamais oublier
un effet qui est extrêmement important
que les spécialistes nomment les faits
youporn ou pornhub et ça ça évite
énormément de bébé alors ensuite est-ce
que le baby boom nous tueraient à la
place de la coved le à la place de la
coved peut aussi être remis en question
parce que là covin ne nous tue pas enfin
elle tue les personnes âgées c'est vrai
beaucoup à partir de 60 ans mais avant
beaucoup moins il faut quand même bien
avoir les chiffres en tête
aujourd'hui après des mois et des mois
de pandémie on a un million deux cent
seize mille jours je vous parle
personnes qui sont décédées de lakovic
19 dans le monde c'est-à-dire moins d'un
dix millième de la population mondiale
donc là que vides ne nous tue pas si
malgré tout ça il ya effectivement un
baby boom et bien oui c'est plutôt une
mauvaise nouvelle et là je vous en
réfère puisque ce plastique et une pub
pour mon livre précédent qui s'appelle
permet de procréer qui explique qu'il y
a un lien indéfectible extrêmement
dangereux entre la démographie mondiale
la démographie humaine et la crise
environnementale plus nous sommes
nombreux et surtout plus nous sommes
nombreux en occident puisque notre mode
de consommation n'est pas du tout
durable plus la crise environnementale
promet d'être forte
donc oui si on peut éviter de trop se
reproduire malgré confinement
ça serait quand même mieux
pour